e aí
ah pois como é que você se sentiram
tirando o calor tirando o calor estive a
comunicar com as minhas mãos com os meus
braços mas nenhum de vocês me conseguir
entender então eu faço sempre isto
porque como o tradutor intérprete tenho
a inclusividade sempre mente nos
próximos eventos é raro termos aqui como
neste palco e intérpretes de língua de
sinais e por isso é que eu faço este
gesto sempre para consciencializar as
pessoas ouvintes sobre a importância da
língua de sinais então ser tradutor é
é muito obrigada
o tradutor intérprete das pessoas
perguntam ou sandra
e eu pego no texto copy-paste tem
algumas plataformas que me fazem uma
tradução automática então por que ser
tradutora porque ser intérprete muito
simples você já tentaram colocar nessas
plataformas
em qualquer palavra qualquer frase que
envolvesse graças a plataforma vamos
saber dizer se estão a referir-se a
copos vidros óculos
e o ser humano é que dá o contexto e aí
vem a importância da profissão que
exerço já 14 anos então o que é estudar
traduzir mundo muito muito simplesmente
traduzir é pagar não teste ou não
discurso numa língua de partida portanto
original e gerar um teste equivalente na
língua de chegada que é a tradução isso
é que eu faço então vamos contar a
história de uma moça que eu admiro muito
o nome dela é débora débora se isso ela
inglesa e pasmem ela lê 200 livros por
ano ela tem de explicar o segredo e esta
moça graduou-se no curso de linguística
mas não conseguiu uma colocação e ela
disse olha que você é tradutora mas
tradutora no lixo muito particular a
tradução literária
oi e ela sendo pragmática foi pesquisar
qual era o par linguístico mais raro que
existe então vocês diz a sandra para
linguístico o que é isso imagina sabe
quantas línguas se falam no mundo alguém
quer a lançar um número
o 6.909 é uma estimativa quem fala mais
do que uma língua levante o braço
é muito parabéns vocês estão melhores do
que três quartos dos adultos do mundo
que falam apenas uma língua daí a
importância do tradutor e então a débora
voltando a história dela foi à procura
do par linguístico menos comum para a
língua materna dela que ela é inglesa
como disse e ela escolheu o coreano
e ela pegou no livro do coreano e
começou da aula um em casa e durante
dois anos aprender o coreano e foi à
procura de autor as coreanas para
traduzir ela selecionou um romance uma
novela de fato chamada a vegetariana
dean e pajens na tradução de estreia da
débora ela ganhou o maior prémio
literário do mundo anglófono comando
booker prize imaginem uma mulher com um
plano da verdade
e então quem me dera poder dizer que o
meu percurso foi igual ao da débora o
meu foi muito mais orgânico porque os
nossos e messias não me apresentaram
aqui eu estudei durante sete anos deve
ser dura e urbanismo
bom então imagina o que é sete anos de
carteira canudo na mão três estágios 1
o que sentir uma completamente
desmotivada
e desde pequena que falo línguas não há
escolha uma débora a dedo e eu falo
línguas normais em inglês e italiano as
outras não vou dizer porque não falo só
o e então vejo uma sim aos 27 anos falo
línguas ok que que eu vou fazer isso vou
fazer uma empresa computador fax acho
que vocês estão muito novos não se
lembram fax procedeu ao e-mail eu tive
um fax e então imagina eu ainda
desliguei o telefone assim
e aí
o posto isto foi construído a minha base
de clientes imagina naquela altura em
maputo não havia internet rápida eu
tinha direito internet café acho que já
não existem
e hoje o cenário é completamente
diferente e organização para que eu
trabalho faz tenta contribuir para
melhorar essa situação porque nós temos
um fato muito mal em moçambique que é
primeiro temos poucas mulheres a
ingressar para o curso de tradução e
interpretação que temos o m que está dar
a em nível de licenciatura e temos é o
pé que está dar em nível de mestrado mas
temos um número muito reduzido de
mulheres que ingressam e o número ainda
menor de mulheres que terminam este
curso e as que terminam onde é que
acabam como recepcionistas quando elas
estão sentadas em cima de uma mina de
ouro com a débora descobriu
bom então a minha batalha nisso e todos
os anos desde 2015 promove uma
iniciativa que tenta incentivar os
jovens primeira ler segunda traduzir e a
descobrir novos mundos vocês dizem
descobrir novos mundos mas por que
voltemos 1900 línguas vou ter aos três
quartos de adultos que sofrem mapa então
imaginem a quantidade de livros que
estão inacessíveis a este grupo de
adultos
e daí o filão de ouro para quem queira
desenvolver a profissão da tradução
interno através do nosso concurso que
nós a todos os anos organizamos
conseguimos encontrar podemos temos
orgulho de dizer que 65 por cento dos
nossos vencedores são mulheres e que
hoje estão a exercer a profissão da
tradução a comercial e também a tradução
literário que é uma vitória para mim
e ir nós vemos estas mulheres a chegar
em longe porque assim a tradução muitos
pensam a mas um livro que importância
terá o livro acho que todos nós já lemos
a bíblia então vocês sabiam que a bíblia
originalmente foi escrito em aramaico e
então sem um tradutor que foi são
jerônimo que traduziu para o latim
vulgata a bíblia não teria chegado até
nós hoje então isto a imensidão do poder
que está na mão dos tradutores aprender
uma língua sim o primeiro passo existem
outros da aquisição de ferramentas a
formação mas existe um fator ainda muito
mais importante vocação que vem do latim
vocare e é o que faz qualquer pessoa
distinguir-se naquilo que faz com
verdadeira paixão e então eu penso que
esta é minha missão neste mundo de
passar a minha paixão pela tradição
literária para vocês para que vocês
eventualmente venham
e vai traduzir com o mundo inteiro para
português e para as línguas bantu muito
obrigado a
e aí